hi everyone my name's Tamra chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen today I am
watching starship starship troops star
shrimp troopers they're little but
they're feared starship troopers
starship starship troopers it's really
hard to say for me for some reason I
don't love bugs
I prefer spiders / bugs oh I don't I
don't love bugs cuz they're crunchy you
know when you look at it you're like
that is one crunchy individual y'all
have been asking for more time for the
predictions more than 20 minutes so
quite a few hours ago four hours ago I
asked starship troopers predictions
please and thank you hashtag jammers
never seen with a gift saying I'm doing
my part
it's got 217 response so the predictions
are gonna be let's BAM or something
let's do it
[Music]
I love that I've seen like 60 films for
this series and that is one of my top
favorites why I don't know it's cheesy
as hell
I love the cast I love the bugs and I
love it would you like to know more this
felt like a sci-fi series for the sci-fi
channel on cable that you would see now
but it was made in 97 I don't know why
it held up so well like it was I they
used a lot of CGI it works somehow they
look like cave crickets from fallout 4
and there's like those Spiti pods from
Dishonored some really cool video game
references for you guys it's all I know
I was thinking I'm going to enjoy it
because of how cheesy it was which I did
in a sense of course but I also just
truly enjoyed it I really wish there was
less of the love story aspect in it I
kind of just wish there was focused on
these awesome killer bugs and like this
really cool story it felt like half the
film was dedicated to building up this
romance between Rico and Cameron and
then Rico goes off to date this other
girl who's way better for him than
camera and then Cameron goes off to do
this other guy who's way better for her
than Rico and then of course they end up
in the end because conveniently their
livers were killed and it's just like a
lots of like love triangle action which
I love do not get me wrong I enjoy it
loved in films I'm not a crappy old
canker sore who's like don't none of
matt love in my film no no I'd like it
but in this it just didn't seem like it
was necessary
you know me Denise Richards was
something else yo I don't necessarily
think she's a great actress to be honest
but I think she's as bad as maybe like
the more recent things I've seen her in
and the other female actress I forget
her character's name don't even know her
real name
very
she is beautiful and just such a badass
character I hate that her death scene
she's like it's fine it's all worth it
because I got to be with you once Rico
and he's like okay bye
girl you were better than all of this so
that was a troublesome problem guy who
played Rico had the most incredible chin
I've ever seen in my life I have a
pretty damn giant chain you guys but
this guy was like the Crimson Chin of
chance I hated the smart bug made by
Apple Smart Bug coming soon but visually
cool definitely the giant like armor
bugs that came out of the ground
horrifying and they literally spewed out
lava fire which is so terrified it's
awesome so first thing I wrote down is
is that they're in high school and
Rico's not paying attention and he's no
joke messing around on paint on his
computer r.i.p paid i'm sorry
no just wait one one moment please I'm
sorry's humans supposed to be high
schoolers also also Neil Patrick Harris
is in this I love him she is very
younger this he still doesn't pass for
high school
it's a weird cool I guess aspect of the
story I wouldn't want to live my life
this way but cool for the story that in
high school they also have a lot of
training for joining to be a citizen to
fight these aliens so many like
propaganda commercials throughout the
whole film and they're really kind of it
first a little jarring just stops the
flow of the film at first it seems that
way but then a lot of them are really
funny I loved those the fight scenes
with the bugs were really cool though a
little bit inconsistent with how
powerful the humans guns
we're in the first fight it took like a
hundred bullets to take down one of
these things and later on there's like
hundreds of them coming at them and
there's four people and they take down
like pretty much all of them so it's a
little inconsistent there but that's how
action movies are okay best line in the
film they shocked his brains out it
ended with the two lovers reuniting and
that was a bit much but they live Neil
Patrick Harris lives there's this great
speech by Neil Patrick Harris who was
like in years and years and years no one
will remember that this was the moment
that we won that we basically won the
war and and I want to know what happens
next but I'm not gonna watch the sequels
oh also before this I think something
that I really enjoyed about this is that
I don't know if I would want to be in
this position but girls and guys were
able to shower together they were always
together coexisting without having to
like separate in in fear of like no one
looks like raping anybody so that's cool
that's fun that's engaging for a
military-type type group it's a bit
weird that they're all white and
english-speaking but from South America
Neil Patrick Harris is fun though yeah
so weird I feel like it would have been
a really easy to just cast it in
California versus so on such a weird
choice that you get with weird sci-fi
films I feel like there's always a weird
choice like okay I don't have a
prediction so here's Neil Patrick Harris
on a unicorn listen we can all use that
always not if I have missed the reason
but how have you not seen all these
movies that's a valid question I explain
it a lot I've got a couple videos on my
personal channel and it really though I
just don't really know we're going to
wonder why they haven't made a video
game based off this movie a first-person
shooter for this would be amazing
Bethesda get on it oh I guess there was
but it was
bad Bethesda get on it you will not be
surprised that the actors weren't
informed that they were appearing in a
satire and not a straight sci-fi war
film it did very much seem that they
were really serious the entire time and
honestly I don't think the acting suck
if there were definitely cheesy moments
but I think is this bad it's ever gonna
be like wow camera dumb eye I thought
they were okay you'll love the lack of
gender / race-based jokes and tropes in
this hashtag the future absolutely I
didn't notice anything that I felt was
blatantly sexist or or blatantly racist
there was a weird element of kind of
weird clothes that Neil Patrick Harris
was wearing is like the brains of the
operation I'm kind of just like not CES
with this jacket every death will mean
nothing because the movie has no
character development I don't think I
agree with that for being a late 90s
heavy on the CGI sci-fi movie there were
definitely cheesy moments but I do think
the character development was was not
bad I mean Rico had the rich family he
did it for his girlfriend he was I think
the most bland of them all the side
characters were really great I loved
Dizzy's out her name I loved her
character a lot of people don't like it
oh man I loved it you will want to get a
laser tattoo yes I also wonder if anyone
actually has that tattoo he'll be
surprised to learn that dizzy was the
guy in the book I am not surprised to
hear that girl girl sexy girl put
another girl in there we need another
sexy girl but I loved the character of
dizzy in the food thank you so much for
watching everyone I loved this one and
anytime see a film like this it really
gives me future it really gives me
future it really gives me hope for the
future of Tamara's never seen I just
loved
so much I really don't want to run out
of a giant films but there's so many
cult classics and there's so many films
I still haven't seen I just remembered
that I haven't seen Braveheart next week
is going to be Trainspotting speaking of
movies that I haven't seen that I need
to see and I watched it with a good
friend Jory Caron who will be joining me
for the video Mike where are you oh yeah
buddy kind of get Ike in here next week
y'all I'm sorry here's a picture that
tire over follow my Twitter if you would
like to know more and I will see you all
next week
sometimes my shirts don't show the whole
thing people ask what it says this says
I only date rebels which isn't true
[Music]
[Applause]
you